yes we love it and I'm so impressed you
guys should feel very proud this morning
q what do you think being that you did a
good job it's the one thing that you
really need to nail when you're doing a
Stephen King adaptation what has to
carry over it's I mean I said this on
stage unless I but I really mean it it's
the essence you know Kevin and I have
written adaptations of books before and
you can't be too overly Precious about
it and let them let the the book and the
source material kind of rule your
day-to-day thinking at a certain point
you almost have to read it enough know
it let the backing out of the back of
your hand and then sort of put it away
but you have to really honor the essence
of what the themes of that book are you
know so you could you could change
certain things with certain characters
but as long as you're dealing with the
same metaphors and the same themes and
the same arcs that's really what it's
all about for us it's impressive to me
how much you guys nailed the sense of
impending doom and like deaths circling
like a snare on this family what do you
like
specifically Pet Sematary what was the
one senior like we cannot change that
cuz you guys took liberties that I
actually really enjoyed what were you
like this cannot change hmm well one of
our big things going in was the chapter
where they go to bury the cat for the
first time I mean online you could look
it up and so many people so many fans
say that like that's Stephen King
scariest chapter like the journey
getting there so we really wanted to
make sure that we had that whole journey
intact going through the little gods
swamp after the old you know burned-out
forest and then kind of even getting to
the burial ground like we had us it's
not there or audible in the movie but
when Jason got to the top of the steps
even whispering others breath like 45
like he was counting which is exactly
how many steps it is in the book so I
mean I think does just preserving that
chapter was important yeah it's a great
job it is
you mentioned saying 45 under his breath
I was a testament to your foam I did not
notice a lot of Easter eggs because I
was engrossed in the movie actually only
notice one how many are there laying in
there for people to find there is some
obvious ones you know what was the one
you noticed dairy there yep yeah that
wouldn't is there because it's a giant
traffic sign yes
in the book it's films sales live but
then I saw the TV show Castle Rock and
they did that I felt like Castle Rock
the TV show had just done that so we're
like you know what
we actually looked at the map and we
looked at where dairy would have been on
the map in relation to blood Stephen
King's Ludlow and it actually would have
been on the way with where she was at
that point with him at the time so you
can't hear him the radio but they're
saying it's 4:00 p.m. on the dot if she
gets there like 5:00 5:30 meaning Gary's
about an hour half south of whoa you
guys went deep oh I mean it's a map in
in Judds house I mean a map of Maine and
this next time you see the film on pause
it we worked out an equation how much
traffic there are there's easy ones than
there's ones that are deep dives Kevin
and I love the idea of a film it you
could watch again and again that kind of
has a rewarding experience and you catch
things like I love thumbs that the more
you watch it the more you catch you know
so this we try to make this film on
those yeah so in other words we're not
going to tell you what they are watch it
again see you for print yes we'll talk
more